[Musik]
teil shutdown im advent bundesländer
planen verschärfte kontakt
beschränkungen und ausnahmen für
weihnachten rekord bei treibhausgasen
auch in der korona pandemie nimmt die
co2 konzentration in der atmosphäre
weiter zu und streit um sinkende mieten
in berlin erzwingt das mieten deckel
gesetz von heute an preiswerteres wohnen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport ein sogenannter von
mir
übermorgen wollen bund und länder
entscheiden wie die korona
beschränkungen ab dezember und über die
feiertage weitergehen sollen
heute haben die länder dazu ihre
vorschläge vorgelegt
die empfehlungen stützen sich auf die
neuesten zahlen zwar sinken die
täglichen neuinfektionen im 7
tagesschnitt aber sie bleiben auf hohem
niveau
hier die wichtigsten vorschläge der
länder der teil shutdown soll bis
mindestens 20 dezember verlängert werden
private treffen blieben auf zwei
haushalte beschränkt aber wenn maximal
nur noch fünf personen
dabei zählen nur die über 14-jährigen
und betriebe denen der teil shutdown
finanziell zusetzt würden weitere
soforthilfen vom staat bekommen
das boden sagt über den kampf gegen
korona hildburghausen hält einen
traurigen spitzenplatz in der thüringer
landkreis ist corona hotspot nummer eins
mit einem aktuellen incidents wert von
386 schulen und kitas müssen geschlossen
werden
wir haben hier flächendeckend neue
infektionen und das ist nicht nur auf
eine einrichtung beschränkt auf eine
schule auf den kindergarten auf eine
feuerwehr auf den rettungsdienst anders
ist flächendeckend überall im landkreis
hildburghausen zu sehen und dass die
bisherigen maßnahmen ganz offensichtlich
nicht reichen ist mittlerweile auch den
verantwortlichen politikern klar wir
haben die steile kurve der infektionen
gebrauchen aber haben immer noch viel
zurückzahlen
das ist die grundmelodie und ich glaube
die bestreitet auch keiner cdu und spd
geführte länder sind sich weitgehend
einig die verschärfungen sollen schul
und kita schließungen wie jetzt in
thüringen verhindern helfen
oberste priorität müsse sein die
infektions dynamik zu stoppen
wir haben alle miteinander das
allergrößte interesse daran mit
möglichst niedrigen zahlen aus diesem
jahr heraus zu kommen denn das wird es
uns leichter machen dann auch im
nächsten jahr dann hoffentlich
allmählich wieder günstigeren bedingt
dann tatsächlich die kontrolle über das
virus zu haben aus der opposition kommt
die kritik dass den maßnahmen der lange
atem fehle es wird doch im januar und im
februar genauso kalt wenn nicht sogar
kälter sein als im dezember und deswegen
wäre es deshalb bis mitte märz sich auf
maßnahmen zu verständigen
streit gibt es noch um göller und
raketen an silvester die spd will ein
verbot um einsatzkräfte zu entlasten und
gruppenbildung zu verhindern
der union reicht ein appell der call in
berlin
diesmal macht nicht die bundesregierung
vorschläge sondern die bundesländer sind
die konflikte dadurch geringer ja
offensichtlich und nach dem chaos der
vergangenen woche scheint eine einigung
für die länder diesmal auch eine frage
der politischen ehre zu sein die
ministerpräsidenten geben sich
jedenfalls alle mühe eine einheitliche
linie zu finden zur stunde so hören wir
versucht man sich in einer
video-konferenz zu verständigen morgen
folgt dann eine schaltkonferenz mit dem
bundeskanzler am mittwoch wird es dann
hier hinter mir ernst noch sind sich die
länder allerdings nicht bei allem einig
also dürfen fünf oder zehn menschen
zusammen weihnachten feiern gelten die
weihnachtsglocken bis zum 27
dezember oder bis anfang januar kommt
denn silvester feuerwerksverbot ja oder
nein und ab welcher zahl von
neuinfektionen wird dann gelockerten
jedem fall wird hier übermorgen über
unsere nächsten wochen inklusive
weihnachten entschieden werden
noch ist vieles offen dankeschön für den
stand der dinge
theo koll aus berlin war das und ein
gespräch mit einem arzt der die
strategie der regierung für falsch hält
das sehen sie im netz in der zdf- heute
live ab 19 uhr 30 und in unserer app
können sie auch vergleichen welche
schwerpunkte spd und union im kampf
gegen korona setzen wollen
derweil wächst die zuversicht dass viele
menschen innerhalb eines überschaubaren
zeitraums geimpft werden können
denn mit astrazeneca hat jetzt offenbar
ein drittes unternehmen einen
erfolgversprechenden impfstoff getestet
ihr seid zu 70 prozent wirksam für
transport und lagerung reichten
kühlschrank temperaturen aus meldet
der schwedisch britische pharmakonzern
währenddessen laufen hierzulande die
vorbereitungen für erste impfungen mit
dem präparat der deutschen firma biotec
andreas weise berichtet hinter diesem
fenster wird corona impfstoff produziert
unter reinraumbedingungen schon früh
wurde das pharmaunternehmen aus brehna
bei halle teil eines weltweiten
forschungs und produktionsverbundes wir
sind im juni diesen jahres von ballack
angesprochen worden ob wir unterstützen
dürfen und wir wollen natürlich wir
wollen natürlich helfen wir haben eine
pandemische situation und in so einer
situation muss jeder der über die
entsprechenden anlagen verfügt das know
how verfügt einfach mitmachen
eine der herausforderungen der biontech
impfstoff muss bei mindestens minus 70
grad gelagert werden um lange haltbar zu
sein
derzeit wird hier in brehna auch in
einem mobilen container gebaut der dann
mehr als eine million impfdosen fassen
kann
gut 40 km nördlich der
bundesgesundheitsminister zu besuch beim
impfstoff hersteller idee biologika in
dessau kann nächstes jahr mit seinem
anti krone produkte auf den markt will
spahn ist zuversichtlich dass es mit dem
impfen bald losgehen kann
wir dürfen damit rechnen dass es im
dezember stand heute eine erste
zulassung gibt danach sieht es aus die
daten sind gut und deswegen haben wir
uns eben angesichts dieser ermutigenden
entwicklungen bei der zulassung in 200
von beyond ich den ball ja durch pfizer
im stoff eben entschieden mit den
ländern ab mitte dezember einsatzbereit
zu sein
die produktion läuft und die
logistischen probleme sollen auch bald
gelöst sein
massen schnelltests gelten als ein
instrument um die zweite corona bälle
schneller zu brechen und infizierte zu
entdecken zum beispiel in südtirol um
herauszufinden wer ohne symptome aber
dennoch infiziert ist hat er die
italienische region alle 500.000
einwohner zu einem kostenlosen schnell
test aufgefordert fast 350.000 kamen
gefunden wurden fast 3200 infizierte
kritiker bemängeln dass die
resultate von schnelltests nicht
verlässlich genug sein
jetzt nach frankreich und zu dem was
manche dort eine historische
staatsaffäre nennen mit nicolas sarkozy
steht erstmals ein früherer präsident
persönlich vor gericht
was ihm vorgeworfen wird soll sich 2014
also nach seiner amtszeit ereignet haben
laut anklage hat sarkozy einen
hochrangigen juristen bestochen um
herauszubekommen was gegen ihn in einer
anderen sache ermittelt wurde
sarkozy nennt den prozess einen skandal
ihm drohen bis zu zehn jahre haft thomas
walde nicolas sarkozy vor gericht ihm
drohen eine haftstrafe von zehn jahren
und eine geldbuße von einer million euro
der ehemalige präsident ist angeklagt
wegen bestechung und unerlaubte
einflussnahme auf die justiz sarkozy
weist alle vorwürfe zurück
so schließt ablehnung ich bin sehr
kämpferisch ich nehme nicht hin dass man
mir dinge vorwirft die ich nicht
begangen habe
die wahrheit triumphierte am ende immer
das ist meine überzeugung das stimmt
mich optimistisch nicht sarkozy soll
nach dem ausscheiden aus dem amt
versucht haben geheime informationen zu
erhalten indem er einen
generalstaatsanwalt des höchsten
gerichts unterstützung bei einer posten
bewerbung versprach die vorwürfe beruhen
auf abgehörten telefonaten sarkozy ist
mit seinem rechtsanwalt die abhöraktion
der untersuchungsrichter gehen dem
verdacht nach sarkozy habe 2007 illegal
wahlkampfgelder vom regime des libyschen
machthabers muammar al gaddafi erhalten
auch deswegen droht ihm nun ein prozess
und auch diese vorwürfe weist sarkozy
zurück er kritisiert dass seine
telefonate mit seinem anwalt abgehört
wurden
trotz der diversen vermittlungen ist
sarkozy bei konservativen und frankreich
nach wie vor beliebt seien jüngst
vorgestelltes buch mit dem titel die
zeit der stürmer wurde ein bestseller
der heute begonnene korruptionsprozess
wurde kurz nach eröffnung aus
verfahrensgründen vertagt ein urteil
wird frühestens für anfang nächsten
jahres erwartet
schuldig im sinne der anklage vor einem
gericht in hongkong hat sich der junge
prominente bürgerrechtler josua war zu
seinem kampf für demokratie gegen das
übermächtige china bekannt gemeinsam mit
zwei mitangeklagten
ihnen wird vorgeworfen illegale proteste
organisiert zu haben
alle drei sitzen nun in
untersuchungshaft ulf röller berichtet
es sind die vorerst letzten schritte in
freiheit für joshua wang und seine
beiden mitstreiter von lem und agnes
show warum ist eines der prominentesten
gesichter der demokratiebewegung
hongkongs diese stimme wollen chinas
machthaber zum schweigen bringen
wir wollen der welt den wert der
freiheit deutlich machen indem wir
bereit sind unsere persönliche freiheit
zu opfern
seit seinem fünfzehnten lebensjahr
kämpfen für den erhalt der freiheit in
hongkong auch letztes jahr als die
proteste die welt erschütterten
warum hat sich schuldig bekannt im juni
2009 10 eine illegale demonstration
organisiert zu haben
er wollte die polizeigewalt gegen
regierungskritiker anbrennen
dieser fall könnte die welt auf das
willkürliche justizsystem aufmerksam
machen deren objektivität pekings
machthaber manipulieren
seit wochen lässt präsident die
demokratiebewegung zerschlagen
peking rechnet nicht damit dass die
internationale gemeinschaft bereit ist
wegen hongkong sich mit dem mächtigen
china anzulegen
zu viele länder sind von chinas
wirtschaft abhängig
im gefangenen transporter werden warm
und schon weggefahren
ihm drohen bis zu fünf jahren haft im
schatten der korona krise schafft china
ein weiteres stück freiheit in hongkong
ab
ein besorgniserregender bericht kommt
von der un klimabehörde danach ist die
konzentration von treibhausgasen in der
atmosphäre 2009/10 auf einen neuen
rekordwert gestiegen
und trotz corona also trotz gedrosselter
industrieproduktion und viel weniger
flug und autoverkehr könnte es auch
dieses jahr ein weiterer höchststand
werden die korona pandemie würde nur
eine winzige zelle in der kurve bedeuten
fragen wir nach bei unserem
umweltexperten volker angres volker groß
war die hoffnung dass diese corona
pandemie zumindest dem klima eine
verschnaufpause geben würde
hat es gar nichts gebracht und das hat
nichts gebracht das haben auch die
allermeisten experten erwartet 22 werden
die emissionen in diesem jahr so um die
sechs prozent sinken
aber es geht jetzt nicht um die
emissionen sondern um die anreicherung
von co2 in der atmosphäre und dieses gas
hat eine blöde eigenschaft es wird sehr
sehr lange in der atmosphäre seit
nämlich hunderte von jahren das ist das
eine und das zweite ist die senken
fehlen uns denkt man einfach an die
vielen waldbrände die wir hatten wenn
die bäume weg sind dann kann der
kohlenstoff aus der atmosphäre auch
nicht mehr an den bäumen eingelagert
werden zwei mega faktoren die es einfach
dazu bringt das die anreicherung
stattfindet und möglicherweise sind die
anderen denken nämlich die die ozeane
und die übrige biomasse schon dicht an
der sättigungsgrenze dann geht nicht
mehr viel
aber wenn ich mal eine weltweite coruna
bremse was bringt was dann
naja muss erst mal sagen der weltweite
flugverkehr hat einen anteil von so um
die drei prozent am weltweiten co2
aufkommen 3 prozent soviel ist das nun
auch wieder nicht was man eben machen
muss ist konsequent industrie
energieversorgung auf erneuerbare
energien umstellen stichwort
energiewende stichwort grüner
wasserstoff also wasserstoff der mit
regenerativen energien hergestellt
worden ist und daneben klimaneutral sein
kann
das muss nicht nur bei uns das muss eben
weltweit möglichst schnell synchron zu
passieren die einschätzung unseres
umweltexperten vielen dank volker anders
der kampf gegen den klimawandel bekommt
in den usa eine neue priorität der
künftige präsident biden will ein
politisches schwergewicht zum
sonderbeauftragten für klimaschutz
ernennen den früheren außenminister john
kerry er erhält auch einen sitz im
nationalen sicherheitsrat
außenminister soll ein mann werden der
für internationale zusammenarbeit steht
beides langjähriger vertrauter anthony
blinken
es knirscht wieder diplomatisch zwischen
deutschland und der türkei es geht um
einen vorfall im mittelmeer ankara
untersagte deutschen soldaten einen
türkischen frachter vor der libyschen
küste auf waffen zu durchsuchen und der
nato partnern ein ungewöhnlicher schritt
den auftrag hatte die bundeswehr vom
zuständigen eu kommando bekommen
ziel ist es ein un waffenembargo für
libyen durchzusetzen
bis zum abbruch des einsatzes wurden
keine waffen gefunden
zehntausende berliner haben in den
letzten wochen erfreuliche post von
ihrem vermieter bekommen ab heute sinken
die mieten für rund 340.000 wohnungen
weil sie mehr als 20 prozent über der
festgelegten obergrenze liegen das ist
die zweite stufe des mieten deckels ein
gesetz des rot rot grünen senats gegen
dass die vermieter von anfang an sturm
laufen aus berlin romanesco war viel zu
tun derzeit beim berliner mieterverein
pünktlich zur zweiten stufe des bieten
deckels informieren sich viele
betroffene über die auswirkungen anna
aus schweden zahlt derzeit gut 20 euro
den quadratmeter für ihre wohnung der
preis könnte deutlich sinken
eine senkung geht auf 7 eur 63 pro
quadratmeter durch den mieten deckel
das ist eine einsparung von 13 euro in
etwa pro quadratmeter im monat das
gesetz zwingend vermieter ab sofort
preise oberhalb bestimmter grenzen
abzusenken
bei verstoß drohen bußgelder große
immobilien portale im netz sehen bereits
negative effekte des deckels betroffene
mietwohnungen würden seltener inseriert
von positiver wirkung spricht dagegen
die zuständige verwaltung
wir haben als senat von berlin erstmal
die mieterinnen und mietern berlin
schützen wollen
das ist glaube ich gelungen wir haben
als einer der ersten der sieben größten
städte in deutschland einen mit rückgang
zu verzeichnen denn angebotes bieten und
das erst mal ein gutes zeichen
vermieterverbände laufen weiter sturm
gegen die regelung ein großer teil der
kleineren immobilien besitzer sei von
der absenkung betroffen heißt es wie
große eigentümer auch befürchten sie
gravierende probleme verbindlichkeiten
können möglicherweise nicht mehr richtig
bedient werden und es wird immer weniger
zu weiteren investitionen kommen also
die ganzen folgen
handwerker und so weiter werden auch
entsprechend darunter leiden
offen bleibt ob der deckel juristisch
bestand hat kommendes jahr will das
bundesverfassungsgericht entscheiden
mietervereine und politik raten den
gesparten betrag zur seite zu legen so
will es auch anders machen noch ein
abschied so lange wie er war kein
anderer ministerpräsident von
mecklenburg vorpommern harald ringstorff
prägte dort zehn jahre lang von 1998 bis
2008 die politik jetzt ist der
spd-politiker mit 81 jahren gestorben
der promovierte chemiker begann seine
politische karriere erst mit dem ende
der ddr gründete die spd im nordosten
bundesweites aufsehen löste er aus mit
der ersten rot roten koalition auf
länderebene und jetzt
fußball-champions-league norbert mit dem
topspiel paris gegen leipzig man ja im
hinspiel hatte er bilder 2 2 1 gesiegt
pc trainer thomas tuchel
der steht jetzt mächtig unter druck er
muss die partie gewinnen sonst wird es
eng mit dem achtelfinaleinzug und hofft
deshalb auf sein zauber duo nehmer und
sap im hinspiel vor knapp drei wochen
haben die beiden nämlich verletzt
gefehlt heute sind sie wieder dabei im
abschlusstraining thomas tuchel steht
nach zwei pleiten in der champions
league mit dem rücken zur wand eine
jobgarantie vermisst er da nicht im
gegenteil wenn es so wäre würde mich das
mehr verunsichern als wenn es nächstes
julia nagelsmann und leipzig haben die
viel bessere aus
position mit einem sieg könnten sie den
letztjährigen finalisten in der gruppe
schon sicher hinter sich lassen
ich erwarte ein relativ offenes visier
beim gegner und wir wollen dem final
charakter gerecht werden
der respekt ist groß aber auch die
chance sich gleich noch einmal für die
halbfinal-niederlage in der vergangenen
saison revanchieren zu können
nach dem 0 6-debakel gegen spanien wird
das dfb-präsidium am vierten dezember
über die situation der
nationalmannschaft und die zukunft von
bundestrainer löw beraten der spe
direktor bierhoff soll eine analyse des
spiels und der gesamtentwicklung des
teams in den vergangenen zwei jahren
vorstellen
joachim löw selbst wird nicht dabei sein
die handball em der frauen kann wie
geplant vom dritten bis zum 20
dezember stattfinden dänemarks regierung
gab heute grünes licht für das turnier
das land ist nun alleiniger ausrichter
co-gastgeber norwegen war wegen der
korona pandemie abgesprungen alle
begegnungen gewonnen von der
gruppenphase bis zum endspiel daniel
medwedew ist erstmals sieger der atp
finals und um rund 1,5 millionen
us-dollar preisgeld reicher für daniel
medwedew ist es der größte erfolg seiner
karriere
in london bezwang er die top drei der
tennis-welt djokovic nadal team nachdem
der erste satz an dominic thiem gegangen
war erhöhte medwedew den druck in einem
gleichwertigen machte der 24 jährige
russe am ende mehr aus seinen chancen
und gewann das match mit 4 6 7 6 und 6
zu 4
besser kann man das tennisjahr nicht
beenden
denn damit ist jetzt auch inoffizieller
tenniswelt minister 2020 gratulieren wir
wenn sich paris einmal mehr 4 100
weihnachtsbäume am stück können dann
sind das natürlich weder tannen noch
richten sondern platanen die champs
elysées leuchten wieder und der chef vom
organisationskomitee sagt in corona zeit
seit das hier nicht etwa nur wichtig
sondern überlebenswichtig
ein bild wie ein tröstendes versprechen
auf manches ist auch in unsicheren
zeiten verlass auf den november auch der
zeigt sich morgen neblig-trüb wo es
trotzdem sonnig wird weiß gleich gunther
tiersch marietta slomka begrüßte im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn wir
danken für ihr interesse und wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen abend bis
machen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
konami wir zuschauer in den nächsten
tagen gibt es viele novembergrau ab und
zu kommt allerdings auch die sonne raus
wir haben ja hohem luftdruck aber viel
nebel der sich nachts bildete und keine
luft bewegung das ist ganz anders hier
über westeuropa da regnet es teilweise
auch in süd kann den arien und am
mittelmeer zwischen italien und libyen
bei uns bleibt es trocken in der nacht
nebelfelder breiten sich aus vor allem
im süden aber hochnebel vor den küsten
auch wolken mit hochnebel und david
jetzt in der nacht ein kräftiger
südwestwind es wird frostig im osten und
süden zwischen berlin und den alten 0
bis minus 4 grad sonst im westen und
norden bleibt es allerdings frostfrei
und morgen ändert sich wenig an den
temperaturen meist sind es wieder sechs
bis elf grad aber elf grad nur wenn die
sonne längere zeit scheint und im nebel
sind es eh nur zwei bis vier grad der
nebel hält sich in den niederungen
während hier in den alpen und im
schwarzwald die sonne scheint auch am
nordrand der mittelgebirge kann sie
rauskommen vielleicht auch im nordosten
sonst auch im norden trüb bei einem
kräftigem südwestwind ja die aussichten
es geht ähnlich weiter donnerstag mit
regen etwas regen im norden und freitag
im osten ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut